2 billion of oil a controversial move by
the democratic republic of congo drc is
a new destination of investments for oil
and gas companies it's auctioning off
oil and gas development rights to 30
blocks of peatland tropical forest in
the congo basin welcome to drc
the president insists this does not mean
his government is backtracking on
commitments made at last year's un
climate summit
[Music]
i would like to reassure our partners of
our determination to carry out
exploration using modern technology that
protects the environment the fauna and
the flora and preserves the ecosystems
and ecological balance
the congo basin covers 530 million
hectares in central africa and is home
to seventy percent of the continent's
forests
some of the blocks the dr congo plan to
develop are located on lake kivu
lake tanganyika one is in a coastal
region alongside the albertin graben in
the east african rift valley
other plots are in the virunga national
park home to protected mountain gorillas
and other endangered species
environmentalists and climate activists
warn drilling in these areas could be
catastrophic we're talking about a very
sensitive ecosystem calling peatland
that is storing more than 30 billion ton
of carbon and that is about three years
of emissional year over mission of the
entire planet that means any oil
exploitation in this area would be a
carbon bomb that it really exposed and
the humanity won't be the same anymore
those in favor of drilling say fossil
fuel production would boost development
in one of the world's poorest countries
this is a moment in which we're trying
to promote our resources the democratic
republic of congo is a potentially rich
country but at the moment it remains
just potential the government estimates
there are 22 billion barrels of crude
reserves and is targeting production of
200 000 barrels per day but critics say
there's no guarantee the wealth will
benefit the congolese people haru mutasa
al jazeera